they were witnessing a nightmare it
wasn't even a train wreck it really was
more like an existential shattering of a
human soul
[Applause]
[Music]
super excited to bring this light up its
album that album get wet one of the best
part erotic novels of all time you guys
a rabble-rouser of the seventh degree
give it up for mr. everybody when I was
16 I want it to be a fashion designer in
case you didn't get that impression
already but I wrote a letter to a
company that was actually based in Japan
called calm day garson's
and I want to work for this company and
I was 16 so I figured that what you do
is you write a letter to Japan and then
they hire you
and they actually wrote back through
their New York offices and said if you
really want to work here in two more
years when you're 18 right back and
we'll see what we can do so I waited two
years and then wrote back and then said
yeah I still want to work there so then
I moved to New York and it was given a
job in the basement office of comedy no
songs on Wooster Street and was fired
two months later for stealing and other
petty offenses when I was fired I was
crying quite a bit which the woman in
charge asked me not to do
and I decided that I wasn't meant to do
fashion so at that time I was living in
the living room of two folks from
Michigan who I didn't know really and
looking through the want ads every day
in the back of a The Village Voice and
came across a job for a musician I
thought huh I've never thought about
doing that now I had taken piano lessons
and played piano and made music but that
to me was like reading I never really
thought you know once you learn how to
talk you don't necessarily become
professional unless you're gonna be a
stand-up comedian or something like that
anyway so he's easier than I thought
because I didn't I wasn't even supposed
to be a joke so I thought well at the
worst case I mean the job beats $700 a
week which was more money than I'd ever
imagined you could really make doing
anything was a lot more than I was
getting paid at the internship at the
fashion place so I said okay I'll try
now I figured having never auditioned
for a musical job before then I would go
in and I would have a meeting and they
would give me songs to learn and we
would talk about the band I had only
been in high school bands and things
like that we did have original songs but
I think we once learned someone else's
song and played it very poorly and it
took about two or three months of
practice before we got it and then we
never played it again went back to the
original songs because no one could
judge those so I dressed up as most
professional musicians did at the time
which I ambition to be a sport coat and
with the sleeves rolled up and when I
got myself psyched up and really tried
to use the power visible visualization
which had just been learning about at
that time that you could kind of picture
how things would go I learned actually
doing piano recitals to picture the
recital going well and then when it goes
terribly wrong and you mess up much like
the way I feel now on this stage
you'll have at least be able to compare
it and really realize how poorly it's
going compared to what you visualize so
uh I visualized I would get to sit in a
room maybe with the piano kind of like I
imagine will be like a ballet studio for
some reason with mirrors along one side
and a railing and this nice gentleman
who's gonna give me the stack of songs
to learn come back in two weeks we'll
review we'll go over this as much time
as you need and I make my way down there
in the subway you know all by myself I
didn't have any friends really that at
that time I had two roommates that I was
irritating but I don't think they would
have considered themselves my friends
and then uh found my way to this place
which was in Greenwich Village
it was said on the size of Cafe Wha in
kind of bold colors and I really didn't
like the name and I thought that doesn't
this is not it this is a bad omen so I
listened to a deeper voice that said go
in and I went inside and went down some
stairs and was a very very nice woman
there that I explained I am I'm
answering this ad and she had a slight
look of concern mixed with fear and she
seemed to say okay well you know what
come over here and you could take a seat
in the back and I'll go tell the manager
you're here and I thought this is great
he'll pull me into his office and we'll
we'll talk in the meantime it was a
packed house it was very much like this
in fact I haven't felt as much like I
did that night until this height and I
really mean that I mean my heart is
racing so much so that if I just sit
still I just could be seen to pulse
it's very intense feeling and so uh it
was a packed house it was a live music
club and it was a very boisterous
audience standing-room-only people were
singing along that that I cannot
exaggerate how fantastic the band was
that was playing I mean world class and
again it was in a place at really about
this exact size in the most eerie of
ways
there were a lot of mirrors much like
this and helped make the room somehow
seem more claustrophobic in a strange
way I found the one only person seat for
this this whole Club sat down ordered
sprite and just waited for her to come
and tell me when the manager was ready
so I'm watching this band and then this
gentleman who had been more like the
side man stepped up and took over the
mic speaking with the audience and was
very strange for me at this time to
watch this guy was just fascinated by
his confidence because in my eyes he had
absolutely no reason to be confident he
looked like the friends I had in high
school that were really into computer
repair which was a higher level of
computer enthusiasts and I was playing a
Fender Stratocaster guitar with the
strap at that height that certain height
that just doesn't seem like what can't
can't possibly make it easier to play so
I'm watching this guy command the crowd
and I'm really amazed by his almost over
confidence it turns out of course he's
the host and actually he's the manager
he's the manager how amazing is this
that the manager of the club is playing
in their world-class band
so he's bantering with the audience he's
talking about how great everyone has
been so far what an amazing line-up and
I understand that there's a young man
somewhere in this audience tonight
that's gonna come up on stage you're an
audition for us
and the the first thought was shoot
someone else is gonna get this gig this
other kid this other guy and I'm not
going to get a chance and then he asked
again if the young man would please show
himself and that's what I realized it
was me and I just realized I could I
could sit there and not acknowledge
myself and wait until they passed over
because he did want to keep the show
moving or I could go up there and at
that time that really surpassed any
asking out a girl for the first time
it certainly surpassed having been fired
from that job it was I could tell this
was a the most underwhelming
overwhelming thing that was about to
happen and I was about to actually just
cop out because it was going to be you
know I it wasn't gonna go well it was a
living nightmare and there was a very
clear voice in my head it wasn't my
voice it's kind of like the voice that
you when you're reading a book silently
it's just this voice that doesn't
actually have a sound of course but
somehow it's saying these words to you
so I don't really understand how exactly
that works or who whose voice that is
but it's right it's very intimate you
can't can't shut it out and it said this
is what you're supposed to do so I said
okay so I got up and went on the stage
and as soon as I stood up there was one
of those prison spotlights
and so that I couldn't see anything
except that I was very little and right
away the the the hosts face just sank
because he saw that I was 18 years old
and probably gonna be really amazing or
really really bad and I managed to be
both I think I walked up and I kind of
scooted through the the stage it was
very crowded once you get up there you
realize that everyone's kind of
overlapped on top of each other and the
keyboard player specifically was not
happy about me taking over his at least
three racks of triple tiered keyboards
and then a whole nother it tripled here
and then ones the ones that you can't
play behind you that's always been you
know I can play one barely so this idea
of nine was was again I just was very
intimidated and all the while this is
happening I can't believe that it's
happening and I still think about just
fleeing and I'll try to run through this
poor quick because it's just very
painful to think about so the holsters
here and he says he said okay so what do
you got for us and I you know my mouth
was so dry it was like all the moisture
had gone to my the palms of my hand and
behind my knees I could barely speak and
the mic was way too loud I said I didn't
think it was gonna be like this and
before I could even finish uttering that
the cold crowd the tension it just they
were having the greatest night of their
lives and it was just cut off
they were witnessing a nightmare it
wasn't even a train wreck it really was
more like an existential shattering of a
human soul and this guy hosting realized
that and he said okay well let's go all
in he said well how could you come to a
thing and I have anything prepared what
song can you play I said I don't know I
really was thinking maybe I would play
scales or something backstage I didn't
have the nerve to say that I said I
didn't think it was gonna be like this
on every level you say well name a song
that you can play and this is the part
that I almost wasn't going to tell you
because it's just out of all the songs
the some some that I would know like
happy birthday or something I could have
played that a song I've never played
still don't know how to play haven't
even tried to play especially after this
hadn't heard it earlier that day had no
particular relationship to the song no
special memories about the song I said
Rocketman by Elton John
and at that point I almost felt like
looking back now the voice in my head
like what where where did that come look
at how are you doing that's not how this
is supposed to go so we said okay Rocket
Man and then all a sudden it dawned on
me that this band knew every Sunday new
rocket man they had it memorized no one
gave them the sheet music they they
could I could have call that any song
they go okay one two three four
Pachelbel's Canon and see miracle so
they kick into it and it sounds just
like the album except that there's no
piano playing and I say whoa wait what
what what key is it you know I normally
have the music and even then I need a
lot of practice you see it's on the same
key as the album I said well I don't
know what keys that in and then I think
some of the other bands were starting to
get irritated was starting to make them
look bad and then so we said what key do
you want to play it and I said C C major
but the problem is if you're even
slightly familiar with rock you man
whatever key you started with in the
first few seconds it's changing and
modulating moving to about 18 different
keys it's probably one of the more
complicated songs to try to just fake
your way through and I faked my way
through it by turning the volume down on
the keyboard one of the great things
about keyboards versus real piano let's
just turn that down and have a ball and
then I realized it in all the words so
he said I'll feed you the words one line
as we go I mean at this point my face
was so red and hot the way it feels
right now where your ears are so hot
that they hurt without even being
touched you leave a thumbprint on your
cheek
but eventually I got to the line where
he said where's and I think it's gonna
be a long one time which was the one not
line I really did know so I was excited
and and as I started to sing that he
said and I think it's gonna be a long
long time till you ever perform at Cafe
Wha again an important I was relieved of
course like good let me get out of here
gee whiz and at that moment the crowd
kind of it was just so bad something had
to give because he wasn't letting up on
me and I don't blame him but someone
yell hey let him finish her let the you
know you're doing great kid and and and
the feeling that some other person that
I didn't know that had no reason they
cared about me they were shouting for me
and like a whole sea change the whole
vibe changed to come on you can do it
like like an underdog but I think I
really couldn't do it so wasn't like I
won the game or scored this
three-pointer and brought it all home
finished the song very very badly left
this stage but there was still something
kind of satisfying about it I guess
the bass player he put his hand on my
shoulder and said it's gonna be okay
sort of like you know you're gonna live
through this
and I walked down the stairs and I went
back and then you know very slowly
walked out but uh the feeling was that
if I could not make it through that I
could not make it through anything
[Applause]